with dozens of episodes and hundreds of
tricks under his belt the Carbonaro
effect must have fans wondering how does
this show pull it off let's stick our
hand into this top hat here are some
things you might not know about the
Carbonaro effect in 2013 on The Tonight
Show a young magician named Michael
Carbonaro posed as a convenience store
clerk in order to trick unwitting
customers into believing the
unbelievable
starting with a special Easter skip the
first magic clerk sketch quickly went
viral and eventually led to carbon
arrows regular appearance on Jay Leno's
late-night talk show talking to HuffPost
about the magic clerks gets carbon
arrows magician piers Penn & Teller said
what makes it great is not just the
ingenuity of the stunts which are
amazing but Carbonaro sweet slice style
it isn't just Carbonaro charm charisma
and photogenic presence that helps him
pull off the skits it's also the highly
detailed backstage and under the table
preparation that makes these illusions
visually stunning just give it a little
spritz and then it'll make it floppy in
the same interview with HuffPost
Carbonaro set in doing the magic clerk
segments I'm always reminded of that
line from the usual suspects the best
trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he didn't exist
thankfully carbon arrows best tricks
don't involve anything truly devilish
even though there is the occasional bit
of mayhem and after just one year on
Leno show a newly renamed the Carbonaro
effect was picked up by truTV and an
entire season was ordered even before
the first episode aired the magic clerks
kits exceeded all expectations by
getting picked up by truTV as the
Carbonaro effect after just a year on
The Tonight Show but unfortunately there
was trouble in magician's paradise
according to TMZ Carbonaro was sued in
2015 by Tonight Show producer Beth
Einhorn
who alleged they had entered into a
50-50 verbal contract in 2012 to create
a spin-off show of magic Clerk
tentatively titled trick show Einhorn
claims that the Carbonaro effect is
exactly the premise of the show she and
Carbonaro had discussed and she sued him
for damages fraud fiduciary duty breach
unfair competition and conversion as
20:20 Einhorn is credited as a Carbonaro
effect producer which suggests that the
incident was settled out of court
sometimes the most interesting aspect of
a trick is how it's accomplished even if
that might take the magic out of the
moment because the illusions on the
Carbonaro effect are often so
confounding many viewers can't help but
wonder if these acts are coordinated
according to reality blurred the truth
is the illusions and pranks are actually
staged but only to an extent the
Carbonaro effect has a team of 30 people
and for each trick uses six cameras
picking up a variety of angles that are
later edited frame by frame to show the
trick taking place in almost real-time
the editing process is extensive and
requires incredible attention to detail
in order to show the trick as seamlessly
as possible the Carbonaro effect uses
gentle suggestions like footprint
markings on the floor that subtly
encourages a participant to stand in an
optimal spot for both the trick and the
cameras if bystanders begin to
accumulate carbon arrows team will come
out of the woodwork post as people who
work in the same space and effectively
block the Gawker's view if by chance
someone recognizes the show's host he
simply moves on to the next customer
according to interrobang Carbonaro also
uses an improvisation technique that
involves saying yes to anything a
participant might suggest to get them
further invested and engaged in the
event he uses these techniques to
exploit what he calls the wedge of
belief which is that small space where
an individual has left themselves room
to imagine the impossible is true to
fully capture the trick from all
perspectives including the pranked
person Carbonaro uses his training to
plant a microphone on the unwitting
participants using sleight of hand as
reality blurred points out Carbonaro
calls this a reverse pickpocket and it's
extremely effective in capturing the
shock and all that inevitably arises as
the trick unfolds in other cases where
appropriate Carbonaro steam will plant a
mic in an object like a heart rate
monitor or clothing for the participant
to try on yep we sneak him everywhere on
vests jackets or in this common everyday
upper chest pulse regulator we used at
the golf course
many of the participants are shocked to
realize their reactions have been
getting recorded all along and not just
by the cameras because of all this even
though aspects of the Carbonaro effect
are staged the human
reactions are not that aspect is
enchanting all on its own
what do where do you keep where do you
play Carbonaro is also sensitive to the
nature of his trickery and make sure
that the joke doesn't enter into scary
or bullying territory if a participant
starts to get uncomfortable or feels
they're being made fun of Carbonaro
we'll stop the prank reset and move on
to the next person Carbonaro also
understands that sometimes it's more
than just vanity that makes people
hesitant to agree to appear on camera
Carbonaro totally respects that and
their privacy in these cases he simply
moves on to the next mark three is the
magic number for the main elements in a
Carbonaro effect trick in order to
achieve its maximum potential which
Carbonaro calls the perfect triad
according to interrobang first is the
trick which needs to strike a fine
balance between being simple as well as
appearing incredibly complicated the
quantum physics of magic Carbonaro
returns to magic basics magic 101 that
relies on sleight of hand since this is
the most effective aspect second
Carbonaro needs a solid story to
complement the magic 101 going on behind
the scenes since the Carbonaro effect
often takes place in retail scenarios
Carbonaro needs to sell himself not as a
celebrity magician but as an everyday
Joe who's giving out free samples or
doing a demonstration this is the thing
my boss is like crazy superstitious
without this narrative background it
would be impossible to get people to
believe they're witnessing a miracle
especially since they actually aren't
the third and arguably the most
important aspect of a trick is the
participants reaction to it Carbonaro
told interrobang what I think is at the
heart of the show is the joy of watching
people react to bizarre situations I
could be great but the reaction is the
superstar if the trick is really great
the silly story that I tell along with
it is really great and the person that I
am lucky enough to have wandered into
this scenario is also an awesome person
if those three things are lined up it's
golden Impractical Jokers is another
hidden camera prank show featured on
truTV that involves a group of four
friends daring each other into
increasingly ridiculous and personally
embarrassing situations the person who
refuses loses and is faced with an even
more absurd
dare to close out each episode while
Impractical Jokers isn't nearly as
finessed as the Carbonaro effect in
either theme or execution pairing the
two popular shows still makes perfect
sense in a hilarious crossover event
Impractical Jokers stars joined
Carbonaro in a coffee shop to prank some
unsuspecting New Yorkers but as to be
expected with the Carbonaro effect the
joke ended up on the Joker's who are
supposed to be helping prank customers
by the time the Joker's get involved
Carbonaro switches the prank and the
Joker's end up stunned themselves as
Carbonaro smooth magic takes place right
in front of them without them even
realizing growing up Carbonaro was
inspired by the prank show candid camera
and first got into magic by intimidating
his hero David Copperfield in an
interview with Newsday Carbonaro
recalled I learned how to be a performer
by emulating him as a kid his formula of
just talking to people on stage being
free to improvise being charming and
witty with a crowd together with great
beautiful magic after summers attending
Tannen's magic camp he went on to teach
himself a variety of magic tricks and
sleight of hand through relentless
practice in front of a mirror until the
illusions were seamless once he was able
to fool his family they joined forces to
help him to branch out and get paid for
his performances starting when he was
just 13 encouraged by his electrician
dad who had helped build SATs first
tricks and his nurse mom who took on the
role of both Booker and manager for her
son carbon arrows flare for both magic
and performing flourished he made so
much money performing magic tricks
during high school that he saved enough
to put himself through the prestigious
and expensive NYU where he studied
acting professionally in an interview
with interrobang about his magical
training Carbonaro said I had this
love-hate relationship with magic magic
can sometimes be a bad word a lot of
people they think of their dumb uncle or
some stupid clown that they saw they
don't really know that magic can be
super skilled and super wonderful the
way the Carbonaro effect approaches
magic is absolutely both of those things
super skilled and super wonderful
inspired by the practical special
effects of horror movies as well as
Steven Spielberg films like jaws and
Jurassic Park Carbonaro insists that the
tricks must be doable in real time they
don't even use camera tricks Carbonaro
and his writing room use an
unconventional reverse method in
conceiving their tricks instead of
thinking about what they can do they
think
about something impossible to do and
then work out the details of how to
accomplish it successfully on camera he
likens some of their concepts to
episodes of The Twilight Zone explaining
that they think of something that might
be considered terrifying or creepy and
turn it into a magic trick that leaves
people stunned more than frightened
Carbonaro has 30 people on his team who
help with the various aspects of each
trick and a portion of them are involved
with the six cameras being used this
means that there's always at least one
camera that catches the illusion in the
act which of course gets edited out
before the episode airs the Carbonaro
effect team even includes people with
whom Carbonaro went to magic camp who
continued helping him design and execute
these magical moments as Carbonaro likes
to call his tricks as much as Carbonaro
would love to practice and hone his
tricks more with participants the
Carbonaro effect has a limited timeline
to film ten episodes in a mere 13 weeks
this amounts to upwards of one hundred
and forty tricks that he and his team
must not only design but rehearse
without the beautiful human reactions
that really bring the magic home for
example the stunning everlasting juicer
trick was shot a grand total of two
times the level of creativity displayed
here is as stunning as the magic and
carbon arrows performances themselves
are you kidding me is this like am I
being punked right now the Carbonaro
effect host might be born and raised in
Long Island but his show has been filmed
in Georgia and Chicago to capitalize off
of a potentially less cynical population
as Carbonaro told a.m. New York
locations are also easier to disguise
far from a well photograph to New York
landscape that might alert people to
carbon arrows presence and upstage the
tricks with participants who know too
much about him already that said
Carbonaro already knows exactly what
trick he would do if given the chance to
bring the Carbonaro effect to his home
state and of course it involves the
subway he hasn't revealed a lot of
detail only that it would rely on a
subway platform a moving train and
Carbonaro being in his words a nutjob
the focus would be on the subway riders
faces as they watch the scenario unfold
Carbonaro also thinks filming around New
York would be great because of all the
swearing that would inevitably need
bleeping out as his tricks unfold no no
I'm sorry no check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]